this is the Ingram angle from a very
busy Washington tonight jam-packed show
everything you need to know about this
sad sad showing on Capitol Hill by Bob
Muller Ken Starr Saul Eisenberg mark
Meadows Dan bungee know Chris Hahn Ari
Fleischer and we even have a body lying
language breakdown on Muller an expert
who worked closely with him also for
years you're not going to believe what
he has to say about today's testimony
but first Trump beats the elites again
that's the focus of tonight's angle when
he was appointed special counsel Robert
Muller was described by the political
legal and media elite as a brilliant
choice there is no more respected figure
in American law enforcement than Bob
Mollica stellar reputation for no non
no-nonsense he's the pro he's gonna
follow the facts where they leave this
is big stuff and Bob Muller is the guy
to do this is going to be resolved by
one man sitting quietly at his desk
named Robert molar Bob Muller completed
and another tour of duty well at the
time I might have been the only one who
wasn't buying it I'm sick of hearing
what a great special prosecutor Bob
Muller is I'm sick of hearing them all
give cover to Bob Muller they should
stand up and say we'll see where this
goes well I should have bought lotto
tickets that day so where did this all
go well we found out today that when we
saw a man who well we thought was going
to be well prepared wasn't I don't have
it in front of me I take your word and I
have not familiar with that I am NOT
certain of the person who originally
copied that quote I don't know that for
sure I can't answer that question
without knowing more about that the
question a man who wasn't well versed in
the details of the investigation I like
to ask you the reason again that you did
not indict Donald Trump is because of
OLC opinion stating that you can on a
date a sitting president
that is correct a man who had to come
back after break and correct that very
answer I want to go back to one thing
that was said this morning by mr. Lu who
said and I quote you didn't charge the
president because of the OLC opinion
that is not the correct way to say it we
did not reach a determination as to
whether the president committed a crime
and that was just a small part of it so
after all that the same media
establishment who lauded Muller from the
start it was reduced to admitting this
about today's proceedings a whole lot of
Democrats were on social media during
this just calling it an out-and-out
disaster a televised disaster on optics
this was a disaster I thought it really
was in a very ineffective the Democrats
have to be disappointed he look who's
winning now it certainly seems like
Donald Trump is winning finally some
honesty from Jeff Toobin look anyone can
have a bad day you know I'm a lawyer too
and I was involved in a lot of
white-collar investigations really big
corporate investigations you don't
always hit homeruns but this was a day
full of swings and misses and an
investigation that was in search of a
crime from the very beginning and anyone
but rank partisans would come to the
same conclusion at this point if Muller
was the consummate Pro that everyone
said he was he would have used today to
apologize to the American people and
this president for what ultimately was a
travesty we'll never know the full
extent of how much this is hobbled the
presidency of Donald Trump but I have to
say this even with this albatross around
his neck the president has once again
beaten the elites at their own game he's
delivered economic success that's the
envy of the world better try harder next
time guys and that's the angle